a national monument and symbol of south
african democracy up in flames
a fire tore through cape town's
buildings of parliament sunday severely
damaging the offices of south africa's
ruling party
and later spreading to the national
assembly
south african president cyril ramaphosa
calling it a devastating event
but insisting that the work of
parliament must go on
much as it is disappointing devastating
there is something
that we can be grateful for for these
men and women
in
uniform who
go into the most dangerous places that
you can ever think of risking their limb
and their lives
the devastation occurred on the heels of
the state funeral of archbishop desmond
tutu held a day earlier just streets
away the president and many of south
africa's high-ranking politicians
already in the city to honor the
anti-apartheid hero arch
would have been devastated as well
because this is a place that
he not only supported prayed for
and wanted to see us
the repository
of the democracy that he worked so hard
for
dozens of firefighters spent all sunday
tackling the blaze police and medical
units were also on standby though no
casualties were reported
this is a very sad day for our democracy
because parliament is the home of our
democracy
and parliament is also a strategic key
point the national assembly is a symbol
of south africa's democracy here is
where the president delivers his state
of the nation address and it's also
where nelson mandela was elected as the
first black president of south africa of
course it's a place that attracts
tourists from all around the world
next month president cyril ramaphosa is
expected to deliver that state of the
nation address
many might expect that this will no
longer be the scene
the incident igniting a long-time debate
to move parliament to the country's
capital pretoria
but for a place that serves such a
pivotal role during south africa's
apartheid era that is a move many south
africans feel would strike a painful
chord
jillian wolf al jazeera cape town